patrick vincent bonsoir vous êtes
directeur dans les yvelines de l'office
national des anciens combattants et
victimes de guerre on va parler d'une
exposition consacrée à la dissidence en
martinique et en guadeloupe pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale elle s'ouvre
tout juste du côté de la médiathèque
aimé-césaire donc à la verrière
j'aimerais tout d'abord souligner que
c'est une période assez méconnu de
l'histoire française en effet ces
raisons pour laquelle l'état voulu
organiser cette exposition historique et
rendre hommage à tous ces femmes et ces
hommes qui se sont dévoués pour un peu
sauvé l'honneur du pays et notamment à 7
à l'occasion de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé qu'on va faire une
concomitance entre ces deux périodes
soit à travers des hommages
départementaux puisque le préfet des
yvelines a rendu hommage à houilles pour
le 10 mai
2013 et donc l'exposition la dissidence
a été dans cadre du 100e anniversaire de
naissance d'aimé césaire présenté avec
plaisir par la communauté de
l'agglomération je vois de 2,50 et en
yvelines pendant une semaine jusqu'à
lundi de la pentecôte alors je vais
redonner le contexte un jeu en 1940 sur
l'opposition d'une partie de la classe
politique de la population locale mais
l'amiral robert qui représente l'origine
de vichy aux antilles veut s'assurer de
la fidélité des îles au maréchal pétain
privé de liberté ils craignent aussi
peut-être un retour de l' esclavage les
difficultés au quotidien les antillais
entre en dissidence est-ce qu'ils sont
nombreux à avoir fait ce choix cette
époque plusieurs milliers aussi bien des
hommes que des femmes toutes générations
confondues soit sur le terrain dans les
trois départs vingt trois colonies
puisqu'elle évoque la guadeloupe la
martinique et la guyane à sécuriser la
côte étaient des colonies ce n'est pas
encore les territoires d'outre-mer
et pour les plus jeunes vers 42 43 et
s'engage dans les forces françaises
libres ils rejoignent soit des
formations aux états unis soit en
angleterre sous l'égide du général de
gaulle comment ils font justement pour
partir pour s'organiser parce que c'est
très compliqué c'est un peu le système d
et malheureusement pour beaucoup c'est à
dire du mal heureusement parce qu'un
certain nombre sont morts dans l'air en
cas de naufrage il utilisait tout un tas
de bateaux à leur disposition sous le
feu des sous la halle et les yeux
malveillance l'on peut dire du régime de
vichy
et pour ça qu'il ya une partie qui sont
malheureusement décédés à cette
exposition c'est 24 panneaux sont 15
exemplaires à peu près qu'est ce qu'on y
découvre qu est ce qui est présenté à la
fois déco du et des inconnus dans les
connu bas vous avez aimé césaire qui a
été un peu la figure de proue avec son
épouse pour la résistance intellectuelle
et puis des hommes et des femmes des
jeunes et des plus jeunes et des moins
jeunes qui au quotidien sur l'histoire
des de la guadeloupe et de la martinique
et à travers leurs faits et gestes
comment ils ont pu résister y compris
ceux qui ont été décorés par président
sarkozy récemment de la légion d'honneur
pour les survivants qu'on a pu retrouver
et les grands thèmes de la deuxième
guerre mondiale malheureusement qui ne
doit pas être oubliée pour toutes les
générations comment vous expliquez que
jusqu'à maintenant parce que vous
évoquez nicolas sarkozy qui a engagé
justement c'est ce processus de
reconnaissance en quelque sorte comment
vous expliquez que jusqu'à cette période
début des années 2000 dit si on en est
très peu parlé c'était un tabou je ne
pense pas parce que je peux pas me
positionner par rapport aux politiques
qui pourraient venu leur répondre que
moi mais quand vous avez l'exemple qu'il
n'existe pas encore dans cette loupé dit
d'hommes et de femmes célèbres de l'arc
caribéen parce que c'est véritablement
ce qu'un stick ça s'appelle qu'elle va
être réalisée par
un guadeloupéen
métropolitain aussi mais qui va sortir
prochainement seulement donc une
inconnue par rapport à cette culture et
peut-être aussi parce que les parents ou
les grands parents des jeunes
générations issues de ces de cet art
caribéen ne n'étais pas tellement
intéressé par l'histoire de leurs
racines et pour comme sait pas faire il
ya encore beaucoup à faire pour malgré
cette exposition il y aura d'ailleurs en
marge de cette exposition toujours à la
verrière une conférence samedi voilà
alors normalement il leur dit avoir une
conférence mais nous avons avec un
certain nombre d'acteurs de cette
manifestation reconnu que le week-end de
la pentecôte n'était peut-être pas la
meilleure date même si ça correspondait
à la semaine de l' esclavage de la
commune de la verrière et après le 10
mai donc
celui d'ailleurs qui est un peu
l'origine de cette exposition et de la
future encyclopédie monsieur hazell
mathieu qui est un guadeloupéen de
grande qualité romancier écrivain et et
hauts fonctionnaires
reviendra à un autre moment sur le site
de saint quentin en yvelines et
d'ailleurs j'appelle volontaires tous
les élus qui peuvent vous accueillir
pour une conférence de la communauté
antillaise sur saint quentin en yvelines
donc c'est un droit qui est cette
conférence qui était prévu toujours
annoncé d'ailleurs pour le samedi 18 mai
n'aura pas lieu alors sera reportée à
une date ultérieure bien sûr nous vous
donnons cette information dans une
prochaine édition du 7 8 juste pour
conclure on peut peut-être parler du
travail que vous menez aussi avec avec
l'office ça fait partie de vos missions
notamment de mener ses expositions ce
n'est pas la seule mission que nous
menons en dehors de cette exposition
donc nous avons une vingtaine
d'expositions qui sont toutes gratuites
et qui peuvent être empruntés par tout
un tas de d'organismes publics ou privés
pour les devoirs de citoyenneté nous
travaillons avec la maison de
jean monnet à bazoches dans les yvelines
pour présenter la nouvelle exposition
sur la citoyenneté et dans le cadre
européen et autrement nous avons une
grosse activité sociale puisque le
devoir de solidarité avec les toutes les
générations est une imposition légal et
et morale merci d'être venu nous parler
de vos activités de cette exposition qui
se déroule du 14 au 18 mai dissidence en
martinique et en guadeloupe puis ceux
qui veulent vous rencontrer également
vous pouvez les rencontrer les
accueillir dans vos locaux caserne
d'artois c'est à versailles